and finally new rule someone has to tell
me how it how it can possibly be that
this fresh-faced ingenue this forever
young rebel
this out-of-control crazy person is in
five days going to be sixty years old
okay
great now I'm getting good for you
you're still alive applause to those of
you are facing the same decade just
remember this about being in our 60s
among old people were the youngest now
on the occasion of this milestone
birthday I would like to make a request
of you my wonderful loyal audience which
I must point out I have never done
before
I don't burden the audience with my
personal [ __ ] celeb ik let me prove it
to you
and everybody shut the [ __ ] up you got
to talk the whole show
politically-incorrect went on the air in
1993 and in 23 years over two shows and
three networks I've had tragedies deaths
in the family death threats health
issues bad breakups speaking strictly
for me it never felt right to bother the
audience with any of it when my mother
died the last people I wanted to have to
deal with it was you
and it certainly never been your job to
worry why Stedman won't marry me never
brought any of it up if I had a book to
sell I mentioned it a few times I didn't
badger and bore you with it for months
buy my book buy my book other shows are
always begging the audience every five
minutes to like is like me please like
me I would never ask you to be our
unpaid intern and publicity Department
I'm old school show business you're not
here for me I'm here for you
it's like it's like when you're at a
concert and the lead singer holds the
mic up to the crowd [ __ ] you you sing I
pay my point is I'm not overdrawn at the
favor Bank but now that I'm 60 I better
make a withdrawal soon so yes there is
something I want you guys to help me
with and it's this
before he leaves office I want to get
President Obama on this show
in case you don't know who Obama is
and let's just say our invitation has
gotten lost in the mail for seven years
which would be okay except the fact that
in that time this president has done
virtually every other show in the known
universe and I don't just mean other
comedian shows another opinion giver
shows
I mean mr. president you've done
everything but ultimate fighting in
amateur porn you sat between two ferns
and went to Marc Maron's garage and
talked about your hair with Kelly and
Michael and did your March Madness
brackets on SportsCenter you did this
show on YouTube which would bother me
even more except I'm actually a big fan
of Kevin Hart
mr. president you went on this show
so clearly this isn't about the dignity
of the Oval Office if you went any lower
you'd be on Fox and Friends
Jesus Sean Penn can get an interview
with El Chapo but I I can't get on the
president he'll talk to the lady with
the green lips so I just want to know
why not ask I'm curious because I would
hate to think that it's that I have to
always agree with you on everything to
get into the club when actually I have
been pretty damn supportive as a
president ever had a better week than
the week this president had he's smart
he's honest I mean he actually did
something amazing nobody's budget has
the balls to put it Social Security on
the table Obama did to women on the
Supreme Court
bin Laden's dead stock market at record
Heights an unemployment rate that
dropped from ten point two to five point
nine the Jackie Robinson of American
politics but you know Obama he's always
cool about this [ __ ] I notice a guy one
so what engine just tell me what is it
is it that I'm a pothead because you
went on Zach's show and he's such a
pothead he once lit up sitting right
there
is it the atheist thing I know that's a
political third rail to sit down with
the godless but you know what atheists /
agnostics / we just want to sleep in on
Sundays is now the second biggest demo
in the religious survey 23 percent of
American yeah don't we get some respect
what is it just tell me it can't be that
we don't have enough viewers because
real time gets over 4 million which is a
lot these days into Andy and the quality
of our audience excuse me for saying so
other shows but the real time viewer is
I'm sorry
the absolute best
and I am NOT just I am not just blowing
smoke up your ass although if you stick
around after the show it's been known
that there could be no better audience
for this president our viewers are
informed they are engaged and they're
smart enough to steal cable I ought to
know because my relationship with the
audience is the relationship of my life
kids I don't have time for kids I've got
to rewrite this end piece it's always
where I put my energy it's what I love
the most
that's my truth that's the way I was
born that's what my body's telling me to
do and always has it's why I've always
treated the audience like they're my
friend and I mean a real friend I trust
them enough to say things they may not
want to hear we don't agree on
everything and we don't have to because
friends don't leave each other over that
we even fight sometimes because honesty
is love and friends don't [ __ ] each
other we are doing me for I don't
[ __ ] start with me don't start with
me oh [ __ ] you with the bull
it's gonna be rough unless you get that
stick out of your ass right now you see
how much I love you so now for my big
six oh I would like to ask my friend the
audience this one favor as it turns out
it is the policy of the Obama
administration that if the White House
receives a petition signed by a hundred
thousand people in 30 days you see where
I'm going with this they have
they have to address it so please go to
the We the People petitions on
whitehouse.gov and sign the one that
just says that you the real-time
audience would respectfully like to see
the president we all admire sit down and
talk to the comedian you get your news
from as is our custom here in America